in the laboratory of the Del pesh
Pharmacy in Paris medicines are being
prepared in this case it's the common
antibiotic Amoxicillin the owner here
says since people stopped wearing masks
they are catching more infections again
so the demand for simple medication is
higher and the major pharmaceutical
companies cannot keep up the shortage of
medicine applies across Europe at this
Berlin Pharmacy staff are increasingly
having to find alternative drugs to
those doctors have prescribed in order
to help their patients
basically we have a lot more work to do
to supply the population with medicines
so far we've still somehow found a
solution for people but we often have to
improvise so sometimes we release
another active ingredient more strongly
than was prescribed and then have to
adjust the dosage even simple treatments
to treat coughs and colds are harder to
come by
I would have preferred a cough syrup but
the pharmacist offered it to me in
tablet form that's okay the most
important thing is it helps the same
active ingredient is in it so I'm
satisfied
the problem is not just affecting simple
painkillers and antibiotics across the
continent the European medicines agency
says currently 13 key drugs are in short
supply two are for fighting arthritis
and help combat the symptoms of covid
another two are to help patients who've
had a heart attack or a stroke among the
remainder are drugs to fight leukemia
diabetes and to prevent the rejection of
transplants one of Germany's leading
oncologists told me why he believes this
is happening the major problem is that
most production sites are not close to
us so they're not in Europe anymore but
they're like in India and China was it
cheap but it makes a very complex supply
chain not only in providing the basic
product but the to getting so Europe to
get it distributed within Europe and
thus the European commission has decided
to give incentives for production side
in Europe but that takes decades right
now some say the EU needs to consider
building up a stock of three to four
months supply of the most needed
medications so that shortages can be
avoided back at the pharmacy in
Lichtenberg patients are still getting
the treatments they need but it's clear
that staff here and across Europe are
having to improvise solutions for their
customers Dominic Kane Al Jazeera Berlin